well good morning everyone I think we
will get started well I want to say good
morning and welcome to the American
Enterprise Institute I'm Steve Hayward
resident scholar and intellectual Swiss
Army knife here at AEI and her moderator
for today's panel I want to make a
special welcome to c-span book TV which
is with us taping today having spent
much of my weekend watching the Los
Angeles Times festival of books on book
TV I can add my voice to those already
redundant voices about what a national
treasure c-span's book TV is we're here
today this morning to consider our
current president and his namesake in
the wider context of a recurrent
phenomenon in American politics America
as every schoolboy learns formally
issues hereditary titles of nobility
trusting instead that the ferment of our
republican form of government that small
our Republican of course will summon
forth those noblesse minds for whom as
Alexander Hamilton assured us quote the
love of Fame is the ruling passion and
yet for every Lincoln Truman Nixon
Carter or Clinton whose ambition propels
arise from obscurity and humble
beginnings to the pinnacle of American
power we also see the atoms 'as the lees
the Roosevelts the lodges the
Rockefellers the Gores the taff's or the
Kennedys and now of course the bushes
Peter and Rochelle Schweitzer write in
the book that provides the occasion for
our reflections today that quote there
can be little questioned that the bushes
are now the most successful political
family in American history and yet while
supertankers of ink have been consumed
chronicling the Kennedys the bush story
has hitherto received scant attention
and some measure this has to do with the
paradoxical quality the time magazine
fingered in calling the bushes the quiet
dynasty which I suppose makes them the
Northwestern Mutual Life of political
families the bushes don't call much
attention to themselves there's no
retinue of court poets and historians no
army of publicists but beyond that
there's a certain boring quality of the
bushes I think it may have to do with
posture I'm not sure you know John F
Kennedy could make looking
to make sailing a small square rigged
dinghy look like Odysseus piloting the
treacherous currents of the Bosphorus
while George HW Bush piloting a
cigarette boat looked more like someone
driving a family station wagon to
7-eleven for a quart of milk and here
you can have your own glosses on max
vapors famous reflections about charisma
and politics and although the Bush
family like any large well-known family
has had its share of embarrassments and
personal scandals one can imagine that a
quantitative content analysis of
supermarket tabloids would find the
Kennedys outscore the bushes by at least
an order of magnitude we tend to take
political families for granted but I
wonder whether we should one of the
things that Tocqueville notes in
democracy in America is that while
ambition is the first thing that strikes
a foreign traveler about the character
of Americans it is rare to find in
Americans and ambition for political
greatness or ambition for lofty aims
ambitious men and democracies
Tocqueville wrote our little engrossed
with the interest in judgments of
posterity they care much more for
success than pain close quote indeed an
old man once wrote about this to Thomas
Jefferson in 1813 he wrote quote when I
was young the highest good in
Massachusetts was to be worth 10,000
pounds sterling ride in a chariot be a
colonel of a regiment of a militia and
hold a seat on his Majesty's Council no
man's imagination aspired to anything
higher beneath the skies close quote
well of course some of you may have
guessed that the old man who wrote those
words to Jefferson was his one-time
great rowlett rival John Adams so how do
we then explain or understand the
recurrence of lofty political ambition
among successive generations within a
single family the bushes are now
starting to receive the attention their
achievement deserves so an awful lot of
it is caught up in the passions and
polemics of this difficult present
moment it's too soon I think to render
adequate historical judgment on the
political ideas and actions of the two
presidents bush there'll be plenty of
time for that of course recalling
Churchill's axiom that chronology is the
soul of narrative Peter and Rochelle
Schweitzer have done us the service of
assembling the bush story as an old
fashioned chronological narrative a form
that has gone out of fashion every
we're and with everyone that is except
everyone reader is what readers who
prefer it I think Peter and his wife
have produced a book that will remain a
core reading for years to come as we
reflect on the bushes and with that i
will first turn the panel over to Peter
and then in due course I'll introduce
our two discussants in order Peter thank
you very much Steve thank you for that
introduction and thank you also for
organizing the event here today I think
there's no question that the bushes are
the most successful political dynasty in
American history you can use many yard
sticks to make that conclusion the
number of presidents that they've had
certainly is unsurpassed by no one I
think also the geographical breadth of
their success from New England to Texas
to Florida also speaks to that success
but I think there's a lot of mystery
about the bushes mystery that in this
election year of course has been filled
with all sorts of the theories and
counter theories about how they operate
and how they really work what I'd like
to do today is just talk a little bit
about the dynamics within the Bush
family why I think they're successful
what family interactions can tell us
about their success and what it can tell
us about perhaps the politics a
worldview that the family has now as
Steve mentioned in his introduction as
Time magazine put it to the bushes are
indeed the quiet dynasty when you
consider the fact of their political
success and the fact that there has
really been scant written about the
history of the family it's really quite
extraordinary and I think you can find
out why really for two particular
reasons first of all the bushes have a
long mistrust of the media which runs
back by my estimation to 1950 you know
talk about holding a grudge but in that
in that year a Prescott Bush the
grandfather of george w bush made really
the family's first run for a federal
political office when he ran for the
Senate in Connecticut and in that race
which was very close he had a very good
chance of winning but three days before
the election a walter winchell then
well-known columnist and radio
personality
came out with a story on the sunday
before the Tuesday Election proclaiming
that Prescott Bush was a member of the
board of the birth control League which
as you can imagine in 1950 very Catholic
Connecticut was a very controversial
place to be this story appeared it was
reproduced and distributed at Catholic
churches around Connecticut the problem
of the story is it wasn't true and
Walter Winchell never talked to prescott
bush before he ran the story to get
confirmation on it or to get his
comments and that really i think
poisoned the well for the family in
terms of their secrecy that would follow
later on but i think there's a second
reason why we don't know as much about
the bushes as we would like and that is
in a sense the persona within the family
the grandmother of a george w bush
Dorothy Walker Bush once called it the
Lodi dots and this I think is an
important part of the bush ethos and
that is the sense that one does not draw
too much attention to too much attention
to oneself they certainly don't do that
within the family when we interviewed
family members for a total of about 60
hours that was a constant theme that
reoccurred you don't talk much about how
you're feeling you don't talk about a
self introspection it's just something
that's really not encouraged with with
within the family one of the cousins
relate a story when she was talking
about the bond that she had with the
george w bush and she said that i think
the reason that george w I are so close
is we both lost siblings to tragedy when
we were young at which point Barbara
Bush said oh come on don't be so
psychoanalytical which I think really
personifies the ethos of the family so
there is this emphasis on on not drawing
too much attention to oneself or being
introspective and I think that
contributes to the level of secrecy or
mystery about the family in terms of
trying to understand the bushes as a
family maybe the easiest way to do it
with the time we have here is to compare
them with the Kennedys who are perhaps
the best-known political dynasty at
two of this generation of Americans
what's interesting about the Kennedys is
that they are a model for the bushes but
they are decidedly what you'd call the
anti model the bushes really do consider
themselves the uncanny oftentimes
literally in internal family discussions
they will be considering what decision
to make or how to handle a particular
issue and they will often times
literally consider how the Kennedy was
would handle it and do the opposite and
so I think that is really an interesting
template in terms of understanding the
bushes it's not to say that there aren't
some similarities but I do think that
that that provides a pretty good
comparison well how does this level of
uncanny DS manifest itself let me just
give you three examples that I think are
very important the first one is in the
issue of loyalty no question amount of
the Kennedys are a very loyal family as
well but the bushes even go to a higher
love when we interviewed a family
members and AIDS one of the things that
they indicated to us over and over and
over again is that the bushes will never
have a ted sorensen or an Arthur
Schlesinger jr. someone who really
penetrates the the inner circle of the
family there is within the family the
close circle which is the family and
you'll never have what would garry Wills
one's called the honorary Kennedy's
aides who joined the family you'll never
see that in the bush dynasty they just
simply operate differently in that
regard the second way in which i think
the bushes are fundamentally different
from the Kennedys is that the Kennedys
were a traditional top-down dynasty you
have the patriarch Joe Kennedy sort of
calling the shots telling JFK you know
you're going to run for this
congressional seat when JFK is
presidents you know saying look you know
your brother Bobby should be Attorney
General it was a very top-down dynasty
in that respect the bushes or not I mean
in fact one of the things that's so
interesting is you find that when former
President Bush first ran for office in
Texas his father who had been a sitting
United States Senator was really not
very much directly involved in his
campaign you find you know the rise of
george w bush in
sense is outside of the confines of the
family because family members always
thought Jeb was the one who was going to
have the political future so you don't
have a top-down dynasty when George W
Bush and Jeb Bush say we were not pushed
into politics they are literally being
correct I mean that's just not simply
the way the family operates they are a
dynasty perhaps an easier way to
classify them would be to also consider
them a brand name and by that I mean
young members of the family are not you
know told as young age here's what
you're going to do and how you're going
to do it they are raised with a sense of
this is your identity this is the bush
standard live up to that standard and
it's within that context that younger
generations aspire to political office
the third and final difference that I'll
cover today I think between the bushes
and the Kennedys is the whole issue of
social climbing and I think this is a
fascinating issue I mean here you have
the Kennedys who aspired to be Brahmins
who aspire to be members of white glove
society in Boston you know with with the
cotillion xand the parties with the
bushes you have this strange sort of
reverse you have a family that is
steeped part of the lost eastern
establishment moves to texas and moves
from the White Glove cotillion stew
barbecues in Texas a lot of people
wonder you know is this really genuine
but it is and I think it reflects the
family's tenuous relationship on
cultural issues as it relates to the
eastern establishment so while the the
Kennedys have aspired to climb socially
and become part of the social
establishment the bushes have really
done the opposite they've abandoned that
and and become part of the sort of new
establishments of Texas in Florida well
let me just make a couple of comments on
on family dynamics that I think are
significant when the family the first
one is between father and son I
mentioned earlier that the bushes are
not a top-down dynasty and I think that
manifests itself more than anywhere in
the relationship between father and son
the rise to george dub
you Bush within the family signifies the
fact that it's not a top-down dynasty
the real turning point for the bush
dynasty was in 1994 that was the year
that both Jeb and George W Bush were
running for governor now Jeb's
announcement was expected by the family
and was encouraged by the family they
thought you know this is the one that's
going to be the next generation George W
Bush when he announced for governor
really met with coolness on the part of
family members his parents were
concerned whether he could win they
thought he would blow his top and if you
look at the amount of time that they
spent campaigning and raising money in
1994 it was heavily tilted towards Jeb
and so that's really where the family
saw its future I think one of the
interesting aspects of this was on
election night in 1994 George W Bush was
at his hotel in Houston and his aunt was
there with him and she recalled that
when the news came out that Jeb had lost
and that he had one he took a phone call
from his father and they spoke for ten
minutes after he hung up the phone
George W explained to his an that the
entire ten-minute conversation had
essentially been about Jeb's loss there
had been very little mention of George
w's win and so you see within the family
this sense that george w bush's rise
within the context of the family was a
surprise and a mystery and to this day
there is still i think a sense of
mystery with the father to the sons
political success in fact i would i
would draw the analogy there to the
father having the same sort of sense of
mystery about wrong reagan's political
success he never quite understood how
Reagan had the political success that he
did because his experience had been so
different so I think that's an important
part of the family dynamic let me talk a
little bit about siblings and sibling
rivalry the bushes are extraordinarily
competitive there are legions of stories
that we mentioned in the book then
people have probably heard about their
athletic competition George W would lose
a tennis match to one of his brothers
and then literally chased them to the
point where the the
brother had to climb up a chain-link
fence for for refuge so this is a very
competitive family but they really do
seem to match that sense of
competitiveness with that sense of
loyalty so while George W and Jeb have
certainly been rivals within the family
both ambitious both wanting to be the
next generation to rise to the to the
top top of political success it has
always been in the context of trying to
support the other one well finally let
me just say two points about the secrets
of their success why are the bush is so
successful I do think the way that the
family is structured and organized makes
an immense amount of difference the
reason why for example you have
geographical success in in the Northeast
in texas and in florida is because they
are not a top-down dynasty this is an
entrepreneurial family in the realm of
politics in the way that the Kennedys
and other great dynasties have not been
I think that's made a huge difference
the second quality that I think is
essential to their success is the bush
women of the strength of the bush women
was very interesting about the bushes is
over the past half century you're very
very hard-pressed to find somebody in
the bush clan who is married into money
or is married into a lineage oline wasp
family george w bush certainly didn't do
that when he married laura a Jeb Bush
certainly didn't do that when he married
Columba none of the other siblings have
and I think it is you know an important
quality of their success because the
bush women tend to be very strong strong
in different ways but strong a Barbara
Bush I think is the easiest to identify
in that regard but the other women have
strengthened in other realms as well
well finally what is the future hold for
the bush dynasty I think the the
potential for the future for the bushes
is immense in interviews with family
members they indicated to us that Jeb is
looking very seriously running in 2008
that the families had conversations with
major donors within the Republican Party
asking them to keep their powder dry in
2008 there's also been
walk within the family about Jeb's
personal situation in the context of his
personal finances and would he be
prepared to make a run for national
office in that regard so I think Jeb's
future in 2008 is there whether America
is ready for a third Bush is president
of course I think would be a subject of
heated debate but I will say this i
think that word Jeb Bush to run in 2008
I would certainly at this point regard
him as the front-runner he's a
successful governor of a large state but
more importantly the ability of the Bush
family and their political operation to
raise money and to put literally tens of
thousands of volunteers out in primaries
and caucuses is unmatched there's
absolutely nothing like it in the
Republican Party and I think it'd be
difficult even for a leader in the
Senate or another successful governor
from a large state to match finally the
next generation coming up George P Bush
Jeb's eldest son I think certainly has a
future in politics he's very very bright
finishing up law school worked for a
couple years in a inner city public high
school and certainly seems to have the
political bug so I think the bushes are
a dynasty from the past a dynasty from
the presence and certainly will be one
well into the future thank you well
thank you Peter our first discussion
this morning will be norm Ornstein a
resident scholar here at AEI and very
distinguished political scientist who
has the resume of at least three people
I think what's most relevant today and
more immediately is he has lately been
engaged in the grim and unpleasant
business of thinking about the question
of how to arrange the succession for our
government institutions in the event of
a worst-case scenario of a terrorist
attack on Congress for example it
strikes me that how that intersects with
today's topic is as the Bush family has
a built-in solution to that problem may
never mind Jeb Bush town in Florida
there's another George Bush in Florida
has Peter was just mentioning so norm to
force yours and they've worked out
primogeniture to unexpectedly you know
as I travel or
around the world I have to deal on a
regular basis with the skepticism that
an awful lot of people have that the
American system really is as advertised
that it is a straightforward real
democracy people think it's fixed
because they see these bushes and these
Gore's and these Clintons and all these
others and it's just like they've seen
in their countries where it's the royal
families that emerge and it becomes a
very interesting question to explore
about what truth there isn't any of this
and why we do seem to have dynasties of
different sorts whether we have the
functional equivalent of royal families
or some yearning for something similar
to that so this book is a is a welcome
addition to our discourse to reflect on
it and it's particularly interesting I
think for those who have a deep and
abiding interest in this subject and in
the bushes to read it in as a
counterpoint to American dynasty the
book about the bushes written by Kevin
Phillips which is a very different book
the Schweitzer's and Kevin Phillips look
at the bushes through prisms the Philips
prism is the populace prism and it
really is the fix in the system in a lot
of ways the Schweitzer's prism is a
clear one and I have to say that in a
rarity these days this is a really
straightforward fair-minded book it is
not a whitewash of the bushes it doesn't
dwell on a lot of the items in the attic
or in the closet but it doesn't shrink
from them either and that includes for
example the very tough many would say
dirty campaign that W ran against John
McCain in South Carolina some of the
family difficulties going way back but
all in all it's a fair-minded treatment
what I found most interesting about this
book
and what I learned the most from was
really the family history going way back
and it's two strands of a family coming
together with in many ways very great
differences in ethos and in personality
and you get a much better understanding
of both George Bush and his father in
particular if you think about the
competing strands of the Bush clan and
the Walker clan coming together and
intertwining one being rather reticent
the other being extremely outgoing uh
one being exuberant and in your face uh
the other shying away from any element
of braggadocio for example and you
really see these two strands competing
and some ways more in the father then in
the Sun but a lot of this is new it was
new to me and it reflects a lot of deep
research and some very candid interviews
I think what Peter and his wife have
been able to do is to gain the trust of
members of the Bush family who I think
have talked at least more about their
family dynamics than they ever have
before because they are distrustful of
the press and very closed when it comes
to their own internal family dynamics
still uh while I learned something and
learn more about the sense of the
mission of public service that's deep
deeply ingrained in this family the
noblesse oblige that if it doesn't push
members of the Bush family into public
service or into politics certainly
creates an opening for them and this
sense in the family that you don't just
take the wealth that is given to you
through inheritance but you better go
out and make something of yourself and
better to do it somewhere away from the
geographical center of the family which
is what led to the dispersal while at
the same time you take advantage of
every opportunity given by your family
connections and your class connections
to make it on your own all of that was
also quite in
sting but I still find the whole notion
of dynasty and the reasons for these
families that keep emerging over and
over again a little bit puzzling i
cain't came to the same conclusion
however as Peter did that this is brand
name more than anything else and think
of brand names in terms of the fact that
coca-cola is a wonderful brand name but
it can still come up with a new coke
that Schlitz beer was a tremendous brand
name until they tinkered with the
formula and then it became an
afterthought in American history and
there are coca-cola's and new cokes in
each of these families and you can have
a name and it can be a roosevelt name
and it can be a kennedy name and it can
be a bush name but if it's not the kind
of drink that people want or if it's
inferior and some of its qualities or if
it's not marketed appropriately it can
be a disaster as well what the bushes do
bring to the table besides this strong
sense of public service and besides this
family loyalty is as Peter said an
enormous amount of resources and the
willingness across the family lines to
work tirelessly to make one of their own
succeed whenever they do emerge and that
is something i think more true of the
bushes than of any of the other families
that emerged in this fashion there are
other families that have this
deep-seated sense of giving something
back and if you know any of the
Rockefellers you know how deeply it's
inculcated into the Rockefeller family
that you contribute to to public service
in some fashion but the sense that all
of them will come together whatever the
politics of one of their relatives and
use every bit of the influence and the
money and the connections that they have
to make sure that one of their own
succeed you don't find in the Kennedys
to nearly the same extent you don't find
in the bushes to the same extent there
are uh things that I wish we had more of
in this book uh I wish that some of the
discussion that Peter just gave
comparing the bushes to the Kennedys was
there more explicitly in the book I
I'd like to see some comparisons to even
the other most successful family which
is the atoms really I'd like to learn
more about some of these family and
sibling dynamics I don't know after
reading this book much I know certainly
about as I knew before about the intense
sibling rivalry between George and Jeb
but the dynamics with the other members
of his family including the role which I
find really interesting of door oh the
ones sister with four intensely
competitive brothers following the
sisters tragic death I know nothing
about her and would certainly like to
learn more about that family dynamic and
also more we know a lot about Neil and
much of it in this book and always there
are going to be siblings who simply have
trouble measuring up to the family in
the family name and actually it's
interesting going back to see the
disappointment that each of the bush
generations had with a sibling along the
way who fell short of the standards of
the family but Marvin who's chosen a
completely different path and obviously
hasn't stumbled along the way is a
figure who remains a cipher in this
process and while George P Bush
obviously is is grooming himself if not
being groomed as the next generation
it's also very clear that family ethos
towards public service or not certainly
that's not deeply inculcated in w's two
daughters who don't seem to be
approaching careers of public service
although maybe like their father at a
later stage in life they will move in
that direction or of others or of how
much taste americans will have
ultimately for continuing this dynasty
which may depend at least as much on
performance through the next year much
less the next four years by Bush and his
brother and whether this will turn out
to also to end up being despite its
success like the Roosevelts and like
others when you move to another
generation find that there are people
who look more like New Coke than old
Coke Thank You norm
very discussion I'm going to want to
come back to you and meditate for a
moment on something Peter ended with
that you refer to also and that is that
these enormous family networks that are
set up the importance of those being
amplified in an age in the decline of
party machines and the decline of party
apparatus and so forth sure I think it's
interesting if you what just want one
other note uh that I find absolutely
fascinating and we will probably never
learn about and that is it is obvious
that George w's father has immense pride
in his son and while he never expected
that he would be President and I think
the Sun didn't either until very close
to the time that he ran and won the Sun
is pursuing a radically different course
in foreign policy than the father did
and one could easily argue that he's
dismantling his father's foreign policy
piece by piece and sometimes huge chunk
by huge chunk we know that there are
people extremely close to the father who
are deeply distressed by this you have
to believe that at some level the father
is as well and knowing how he feels uh
this pride mixed with some level of
horror at some of what's being followed
and wondering what they talk about
privately is something that remains a
cipher and boy it would be nice to note
my my standard joke on that has always
been that that george w bush has
occasionally said publicly reporters and
that his model for a successful
president is reagan he wants to be a
reagan height and often thought that
must lead to some awkward moments around
the Thanksgiving table at Kennebunkport
with mom and dad welcome back to all
that our second discussion discussant
this morning is no Emmy Emery a
contributing editor of the Weekly
Standard who not only writes sprightly
essays on all kinds of current political
topics but as herself working on a book
that bears on this subject that has the
title great expectations the lives of
political sons and I was arrested by one
sentence she wrote almost a year ago now
in the Weekly Standard so much arrested
I wrote
in a notebook and I'll just read it to
you to give you a flavor ever thinking
about this quote it is no accident that
the president's whose children showed
the most overt hostility were those of
ronald reagan and franklin roosevelt two
great national leaders who found it much
easier to establish the illusion of
intimacy with millions of strangers than
to establish the real thing with their
children know me well well in a sense
rubra Reagan and prove Roosevelt were
kind of anti cheat on a stick so they
don't quite fit into this thesis but
since I am broke writing a book about
presidential sons from John Quincy Adams
to Al Gore and George Bush you were
brought up to think that they could or
they ought to be President I thought I'd
begin by trying to examine the bushes in
the Covington ask families and see how
they fit into them how they differ and
how they don't first of all I'm in the
ways I'm the tektite ever in am American
history there were three men John Adams
to Joseph P Kennedy and Albert Gore
senior who seemed to have to look at
their sons as they emerged from the womb
and said to them you will be President
one day when John Quincy Adams Boop was
born it was 1767 and there wasn't an
American presidency or even out in
America yet but but this did not seem to
discourage his parents when G Joseph P
kennedy jr was born Amanda 1915 hey I'm
his grandfather the mayor of Boston I
mean down to the boy's parents had
decided the boy would be president after
he had gone to Harvard when Albert Gore
jr was born his father made sure it was
front page news it in the Tennessee
papers and fair after stories about the
remarkable political promise of sun moon
/ off and I'm true trapped in the papers
often when the child was no more than
six the peace aspirations are not to be
discounted or taking a little slightly
I'm all of the sons did go to Harvard
John Adams and son did become president
Joe Kennedy's son had become president
even though it was not quite the son he
expected and prepared many people
believe al gore today is the real
president who has somehow been kept out
of his tattooed to inheritance by all
sorts of nefarious schemes and all these
family's expectations and pressure were
expressed roof relentlessly and often
and Oprah parently to toris currents
could but his regret and that she chose
a p kennedy's senior so i'll put the
life of his children as second lives
have given to himself am i this i think
because the view of john adams amount of
the Gores and i think it distinctly
hasn't talked to view of the bushes who
do not seem to feel that they own their
their children in coop like the same way
there were two other things that
distinguished I'm duties to three men
that the bushes do not seem to have and
they may also seem to explain that there
was usual drive I'm all 23 of these men
took their families in the space of a
few years from obscurity to even or even
poverty to the heights of world power I
mean I think bhupen you make an effort
thuds a tremendous you can be excused
from thinking it shouldn't lose her last
four decks but should be the basis of
something much broader I mean all three
of them felt that they had something
enormous to prove John Adams Boop was
out showing all of his life by people he
considered were flasher and a great deal
worth less worthy he was in the shadow
of I'm of George Washington of Benjamin
Franklin and content of Alexander
Hamilton and Thomas Jefferson I'm all of
whom boop boop where the glamour boys of
the founding era and John Adams always
spells to piss deeply and passed down
the sense of thwarted and neglected
superiority down to his heirs to Joe
Kennedy of course could grew up in
Boston I'm an assistant just one step
short of Louisville apartheid
and a great many biographers trace the
entire Kennedy project to a day at
Harvard in the nineteen ten but when he
found out that all of his Protestant
friends had been accepted to the best
clubs in the school and he and all of
his good Catholics from friends had not
Al Gore of course boo boos wasp but the
wrong country entirely he was for he was
a poor white fruit from Appalachia he
was a condom was considered andrew craig
metal buh-bye trash and looks like joe
kennedy he tried very hard to bring his
sign up as an investor crack who didn't
tell when whatever mistake for anything
else then someone born to the matter and
a prince of the blood the bushes did
don't seem to have any to have any of
these pressures since i always seem to
have been rich and took it to be
socially prominent and well did they
don't seem to have a need to prove
themselves to the world they seem to
have a need to prove themselves to
themselves in each other and then as to
the ways the two bushes maybe not too
unlike the others there's been some talk
here about them being the young
kennedy's but but there are some ways in
which they don't seem all that different
the bush is in some sense might be
described as the walkers in terms of
their genetic inheritance and dissemble
that you're here would be george herbert
walker whose name has now gone down to
do president and if you to look at what
some biographers have said about them we
can look at him and see who else he may
remind him of he is described in this
book as a hard-charging teal maker who's
lost in made fortunes whose
long-suffering wife instilled a sense of
grace and strength at her daughter's a
man who reveled in the pure to glory of
besting his opponent who I'm who love
drew crisped taking who went in and out
of any business
booth ventures who told his children and
grandchildren that physical contest for
spiritual qualities and encourage
certain purchase which one bed a better
person and his children were all
expected to compete fiercely and when
george bush's book biographer has
written first son's decades ago George
Herbert Walker and his daughter Dorothy
had instilled their ferocious sense of
competition in one side of the family
their beliefs of life was essentially
broken down into a constant series of
competitions that had to be Boop on at
all costs George Herbert Walker also who
bought a more pills a large family
compound in care the ocean and Ninja
England that became the home of the
family for many generations and German
became the site of sort of sort of i'm
often murderous sporting events for
years and the bush would walk her house
held that would be an endless series of
measuring moments codified by baba
sometimes called the rankings and often
baited statistical grid that place
various children and grandchildren it
through different levels of expertise
and everything from from running two
horseshoes and as the shriker's have
reprove retinol so family friends would
marvel at the King competiveness and
verbal badger that accompanied any Bush
sporting event on tennis court I'm a
strange shoulder dislocated finger or
spread knees were not uncommon George
once chased a shot at ten aboard I'm in
Kennebunkport and runs the porch
separating his shoulder so in a way it
seems as if George Herbert Walker is
sort of like Joe Kennedy without the
adultery and of course the Catholicism
that was sort of a spur and then of
course seen
there are some similarities that have
been noted in the standard in other
places between John Kennedy and George
to trouble you bush but there are only
two presidents who have been repeatedly
compared to Prince how they both
uncrewed grew up in rich powerful and
vicious and striving families but but
without the sensitive pet either boo boo
could be the air immediately who grew up
in the shadow of someone ahead of him
who would seem to have done things much
better and pushes cases for his father
and I man in Kennedy's cases old improve
brother the pit paper not I'm their
mothers of favorites they they had a
hard time becoming serious or
concentrating entirely until around age
40 at boot which time they became
extremely serious and became
increasingly serious as time went on
their fathers public careers had ended
up in total public group rejection I
mean each of them go on the terrace and
toting through the admiration and the
affection that they had fruit for their
fathers we're cool your uber of their
father's political failures and
determined not to repeat them to the
point of which they modeled their
presidencies I'm in reaction to their
father's policies so the point of which
include they were both widely criticized
for being overly who risked ednan boo
bellicose there were a couple of other
things I just want of like to say here
about dattani stings that there seems to
be a belief that they can be kind of put
in you know over their talents you meet
strength purely on the strength of the
name which doesn't seem to happen I'm
history kind of to tells us that it's
fairly easy for someone with no
qualifications from a famous family to
get a seat in the house well I'm already
a flu so I just
nature but afterwards I McFerrin did not
talented they find it extremely hard to
move up I think the exception would seem
to be Ted Kennedy who was elected to the
Senate at age 30 without having done
much to earn it but it quickly turned
out that that boob was his real level he
turned out to sort of inhabit the same
fruit from inside but but then boo boo
but he ran for president he was defeated
cuckoo quite easily by an extremely Boop
who wait incumbent and am I tend to
think that people like George to trouble
you put push and John Kennedy and Jeb
Bush and Bobby Kennedy who have the
norms in coming and advantage and the
family Damon there I'm the family
equation ship bootcut we still have to
work very hard and to take Luke risks
and to run and click close races tend to
turn out all right the rod tends to UM
to set in but when you get people who
are kind of you who are kind of elected
by acclamation rules little like Ted
Kennedy in the nineteen sixty two or
like some of the third generation
Kennedy children who were scattered but
by political operatives when they were
practically in their teens may seem to
be given something that they don't
deserve but but it seems to me the
Pappas act of kind of skipping over a
stage produces a weakness that kind of
trips them up little later on I think
that Ted Kennedy's have been relying on
other people to clear the way for him
produce the kind of character that could
produce it to Chappaquiddick and then
boo be unable to deal with it moving
poop which of course put put put a
distinct cap I'm on his future and
professions I'm I also think it's much
too early to think that the real
contours of the bush the dynasty because
famous and tarness tease have been some
kind of distinguishable by kind of stray
individual patterns the addams family
boop boop was distinguished by a strange
dynamic in both the sons of John Adams
and John Quincy Adams in which whooping
son turned out to be a huge success in
the distinguished diplomat and he had
two brothers who became alcoholics I
mean who did Todd young I'm out of six
atoms children and siblings two were
successful 44 were alcoholics two three
of them too tied around the age of 30
and whooping group was a suicide could
the Roosevelts were purified by the
terrain between Theodore sons I'm in
their fifth cousin Franklin to inherit
the mantle of Theodore I mean it was a
revival raid that took 40 years to play
out through from a day an intention 05
when for Franklin remarried I'm
Theodore's nintning keys to 219 to 45
when when Ted Ginn jr. guitar hero in
Normandy and of course for Franklin did
Todd is a pooper I'm president I'm
shortly before the war ended and the
Kennedys are defined by death and by
Jackie the Kennedys have this really
tragic pattern on the three successive
poo brothers being fools hope hopped off
and the one beneath them I'm having to
try to step up and sequence I mean in
the process I'm entirely route pre
magnezone put public and personal
profile and Jackie of course has the
profile of Aaron grade-a heroin
affection who has ever lived she's
beautiful she's boob willful
self-indulgent and spoiled but but also
do resourceful and gutsy and someone who
will who will always a crisis step up
and to the right thing that this is the
profile of scarlett o'hara and
we could have been towed out in
synthetic Jackie had aloof lived in the
Civil War she would have gone back to
Terra through through through enemy
lines she would have shocked the to the
Yankee and Boop I'm a tax bill kick came
to she would have cut down the draperies
and then paid them into a dress to go to
and will wanted to get them to get a
match to pay the bill for her and and
sort of at the end I was like taking the
total of one other said a pattern that
seems to be common in two-tone astok
families we saw it in the Jeb Bush
family I mean boo boo Boop which one I'm
child whoop-whoop was under treatment
for entry drug into detection
buh-buh-buh another was being groomed
for political stardom the this is a
pattern that is so common in two-tone
astok families is almost a signature
theme and it could goes back to John
Adams and you can see it repeated in
some way and almost every two dynastic
family and I hope that further
generations of the bushes and Kennedy's
understand this and become aware of this
and try to do more to prevent it before
it comes out thank you know me before I
turn to questions and comments from the
audience Peter I saw you scribbling
notes furiously do you have a comment or
rejoinder to any of the comments that
but made by the panel no I thought they
were all very very good comments one of
the things that Norman mentioned I
thought was interesting is the
relationship between the father and the
son is it relates to policy issues we
never got a chance to know exactly what
it is the father and the son talk about
but we did get indications from the
family sort of what the ground rules are
and I think those are somewhat
interesting after the two thousand
election the first time the family
gathered together in Kennebunkport
something very interesting happened a
George Herbert Walker Bush former
President Bush who always sat at the
head of the table removed himself from
there and asked his son George W to take
it in his stead and I think that one of
the things that has helped the family
um with regard to you know the issues of
influence and family influence on policy
is the fact that the father has this
tremendous respect for the office of the
presidency one of the stories we tell is
how he was called to meet with Richard
Nixon when Nixon was trying to tap them
to run for the Senate 1970 and before
the meeting he went made a point of
going all out of his way to go home
first before he saw Nixon and the reason
he went home first was he was wearing
loafers and he thought he ought to wear
winning tips instead when seeing the
presidents in the White House and so he
has his tremendous respect for the
office of the presidency so he set up
these ground rules in when he talks to
his son we know for example that they
talked several times a day often times
but that the father never raises the
issue himself he will never just start
talking about Iraq he waits for his son
to initiate the conversation we also
know that there were some differences on
the issue of Iraq family members
indicated to us that former President
Bush had some reservations similar to
those expressed by Brent Scowcroft about
possible war in Iraq leading to
instability and we know from family
members that George Herbert Walker Bush
repeatedly said what's the exit strategy
I in the build-up to the war once the
decision was made to go to war of course
the father was completely on board so
there are those differences that Norm
talked about and you know they are so
secretive it's it's going to be hard to
imagine that they ever really fully come
out but it is a fascinating dynamic to
have a president and his former
president father having different views
on domestic issues and foreign policies
as well in late January of 2001 about a
week after he'd been inaugurated george
w bush gave a little talk at the alfalfa
Club dinner which is one of these
gatherings of the elite in Washington
where you're supposed to be funny and he
started by saying now I want I recognize
I've just got inaugurated that there are
some people out there who think that I
shouldn't be president that I'm not fit
for the presidency they don't have the
intellectual capacity to be President
and I just want to say one
thing to you you're my family and I
still love you I want to return to the
question I posed a little earlier a Q
norm and act to the whole panel but
especially norm the decline of party
structures and party apparatus posts the
local and national level it seems to me
has put placed a premium on celebrity
not just family dynasties but the latest
expressions of this of course Arnold
Schwarzenegger in California arguably I
think you could say jennifer Granholm in
Michigan is a similar aspect of this
phenomenon I mean in the old days if you
were a Nixon or a goldwater running
against a Rockefeller you could work the
party machinery and the grassroots
organizations and and and win today it
strikes me as a much harder for a
variety of reasons I wonder when you
think of that thesis and what it means
and so for course Schwarzenegger is a
part of the kennedy dynasty extended the
notion of dynasty a little bit further
than we would have before but of course
you're absolutely right running for
office now is harder than it used to be
and most of what happens is self
recruitment the task of fundraising is
immensely difficult building an
organization getting through the
cacophony of 500 channels and thousands
of bickering voices becomes extremely
difficult to do it does put a premium on
self financed candidates and on
celebrity and that can be political
celebrity or it can be another kind of
celebrity certainly but political
celebrity helps and it helps especially
because at least for some of these
people they've grown up in families
where they've even if they weren't
directly involved themselves and many of
them were and of course what we see in
the Bush family is whenever there's a
campaign everybody pitches in they learn
something about political organizing
fundraising Network building and the
like and they bring that experience in
those talents to the to the table and
that gives people a leg up it doesn't
mean they're going to win and we've seen
all kinds of self financing
multi-millionaire can't
dates who fail because they're not very
good candidates and we do see people in
families uh including many instances in
the Kennedy family who fail despite the
names because they don't run very good
campaigns but if you can run a
reasonable campaign you do have an
enormous advantage and no family begins
to compare to the bushes in the degree
to which they will unite behind and
bring all of those resources all of that
networking in the case of george w bush
and any other bush who runs for
president the tens of thousands of
lengthy personal handwritten notes
written by his father that all become
chits brought back and the cadre of
loyalists fundraisers and others who
will wait until they find out whether a
bush will run it's really quite
remarkable yeah i suppose that george HW
bush signatures probably don't fetch
very much on ebay let's open it up now
to audience questions and comments there
will be a microphone coming around so
please wait for the microphone share
your name with us if you like and the
gentleman here in the middle goes first
yes revolta a Japanese journalist peter
could you tell me you analysis on the
real motive of the gorge wall go to be
the president of the united states and
year two thousand i covered the
presidential election and the current
Hughes told me that the George didn't
have a strong intention to run for the
presidency until summer of nineteen
ninety-seven and what made up his mind
to either run for the presidency that's
a very good question there's not a clear
answer in my mind but I think there's
some interesting things that work there
george w bush is the prodigal son Jeb is
the one who if you look back at the
early campaigns when George Herbert
Walker Bush was running for the
Presidency Jeb was the one who was there
early in the morning state at law is
stayed late at night george w bush
alesso he was less interested in
politics once he became governor i think
he realized number one that he was
fascinated about it but number two that
he was good at it he had sort of this
called natural ability and again i think
the example here of reagan in a
different way is instructive i mean the
sort of the national natural gifts and
abilities convinced him of that one of
the real hang-ups or struggles that he
had in making the decision to run was
concerns about his family Laura Bush was
very happy in Austin she's not like
Barbara Barbara in a sense loves the
limelight loves you know the publicity
the attention that comes with national
natural office that's not the case with
Laura Bush so she was reluctant to see
him run for national office as were both
the daughters they wanted their privacy
as well one of george w bush's friends
Doug Wead who we interviewed told us a
very interesting conversation he had
during this period with george w bush
george w bush told him he said you know
look Jenna and Barbara my daughters they
really you know don't want me to run and
I'm afraid that me running could route
could wreck their lives I'm Doug Wead
said well what about you did didn't
wreck your life
and George W Bush said wreck my life it
made my life when my father ran for
president so I think that that his
personal experience his success in Texas
politics led him to go I also do think
though that when you look at the sense
of motivation that came out of his his
religious conviction of faith is genuine
you know a lot of people you know sort
of wonder whether it's real or whether
it's show I think it's genuine and I do
think he genuinely felt that he was
being called to the presidency and you
know the faith is something that runs
runs very deep and I wanted to add to
what norm mentioned about the the bush
political network what's interesting
about that 2000 campaign that you're
talking about is when you look at the
numbers before george w bush had
announced for the presidency officially
announced before he had held one
fundraiser now he was governor of texas
so he was doing the business of the
state of texas the family network had
already raised 35 million dollars for
his presidential campaign without him
attending one fundraiser himself and
without him you know doing anything as
far as campaign that's an enormous
advantage if you're talking about a
political caucus the bush caucus as it
were within the Republican Party add
something Bush himself during the
campaign got into a conversation with a
reporter about why he was running and it
was absolutely fascinating I mean it
basically was I didn't seek this out it
just kind of fell into my lap and you
know people came to me and so I decided
to run and you know now I'm out here
running and if I win great you know I've
got I'll do great things for the country
and if I lose well you know no big deal
i'll find other things to do with my
life you cannot imagine his father who
was constantly pushing the envelope ran
for the senate the first opportunity
that he had went to the house was really
an i mean a superstar in one term in the
house immediately as peter notes on the
Ways and Means Committee which was the
first time that had happened in the
century as a freshman and then within
two years jumped off ran for the Senate
again pushed every time to find another
place to go
move up and here you've got the Sun
basically saying well you know it just
kind of fell into my lap and if it
happens great and if it doesn't well no
big deal one way or the other after
September 11th he's clearly changed and
believes that now Providence does have a
path for him and it isn't just somebody
coming to him saying q why don't you run
for president you'd be pretty good it's
he has a mission in life now and I think
it's a very different motivation than he
clearly demonstrated before in a very
different motivation than either his
father or his brother Jim yeah it's uh
my own gloss on that is it and I may
take this too far but I've always
thought that political ambition the
higher up it gets the more it consumes
the soul of the person so you really one
of the things that I think probably
upset a lot of a lead opinion about bush
in both parties was the thought that it
didn't mean it wasn't his ambition to be
President was not as deeply inscribed as
it isn't everybody else you can't
imagine richard nixon or jimmy carter
thinking or expressing or betraying
somehow that they could survive not
winning the office I mean it was all for
them and you really does feel the sense
that for bush it really didn't matter
deeply to his soul at the same time of
course the paradoxes paradox is that
getting back to the intense competition
in the family his attitude was well this
is great it's fallen in my lap if it
happens great if it doesn't not but then
he campaigned more intensely and letting
all the rules fall by the wayside to win
because that's the the bush competitive
instinct than anybody else could have
and his attitude much like his father's
about politics is it's like Australian
rules football without the rules there
are no rules you bite you kick you knee
in the groin and that's just the way the
game is played and when it's over you
shake hands and when people don't shake
hands as John McCain wouldn't shake
hands because he thought that the code
of honor had been violated he was kind
of stunned heed it just couldn't
understand that that was going on in a
reelection campaign you can bet we'll
see exactly the same thing another
question or comment from the audience
let's seal do the gentleman here and
then we'll go back over there
thank you i'm jim and i'm looking for a
job network here and as a you opina all
this half the problem still have the
problem when I hear the word Dinah Dinah
ste describing the situation of the Bush
family because I think they still have
to be elected when they run for
president you say you think that [ __ ] is
gonna run for presidency in 2008 so my
question is don't you think that there
will be a development in society here
that the thing we had two of you and
it's okay they did a great job or not
but we don't won't have a third of you
because we are afraid of setting up a
family here who can run for president
with every member of the family they
have that's a good question you know I
think the the bushes view of the dynasty
question is is essentially pretty
democratic democratic small D in that
their view is the voters will decide you
know in other words if Americans don't
want a second or a third Bush or maybe a
fourth Bush for president that the
voters will let us know and I really do
think that is is a view that is very
deeply ingrained I also think that uh
you know the bushes they're real
strength in terms of the family name
comes from the network it also comes
from this sort of brand identity george
w bush benefited very much from the
relationships that his father had but
also particularly during the republican
primary here was somebody who had a
familiar name people essentially knew
what they were getting although there
were policy differences uh and and you
know i think the brand the analogy is is
very fitting I mean people know when
they're going to buy a coca-cola product
generally what that product is going to
be so I think that tends to be the view
that they have and I think that you know
as they look ahead to the future that
will certainly be the you know the
approach that they take you know there
were into a brand names and familiarity
and normally they may know this there
were a few voters in New Hampshire in
1968 who are confused between Eugene
McCarthy and Joseph McCarthy
cars that's right and there's also some
polling information that came out in 99
2000 that some segments of voters I mean
statistically significant number thought
George W Bush was his dad and we're
going to get the old Bush back again and
you know we kind of miss him a little
bit I think the interesting question
from my point of view assuming a second
term for george w bush is it's cliched
to talk about the 50-50 nation what if
the election in 2008 features on the
ballot a bush and clinton again i don't
know i don't think i want to go there
but this is a real possibility it seems
to me gentlemen back over there I'm Bob
Feinberg and I work in banking policy
which overlaps to a great extent with
what we're talking about today I want to
suggest that the book we should be
reading with this book is the culture of
narcissism and that raises the question
given all of this desire on the part of
political families the will that they
have to power it doesn't answer the
question why the rest of us should care
and we're now confronted with an
election where what's at stake is which
of two members of skull and bones should
be the head of skull and bones and in
reality which partners of bipartisan law
firms should be closer to the
administration and which should be
closer to the donor community looking
toward the next race so that we should
be disturbed the question I'm asking
[ __ ] how disturbed should we be about
what this means for the state of quote
democracy and for the presidency as an
institution that it's come to this was
it that the Christopher last book
culture of nauseous oh wow that's a
title haven't heard for a long time
anyone want to take a stab at any of
that I mean I just that was part of what
I was trying to get out in the
introduction is in in this you know the
cliche is this meritocratic country that
has shoes formal titles of nobility we
have these sort of informal de facto not
titles of nobility but there's recurrent
phenomenon a prominent families in which
we draw leadership and I think that's
interesting especially as i was asking
norm when you start changing the rules
and structures of our parties and how
people rise up that amplifies the the
ability of families and people celebrity
to succeed more easily at the same time
what noemi's been talking about and
Peter talked about is there is a cost of
public life whether for a dynastic
family or anybody else I've known lots
of unhappy children of politicians and
and that's an interesting thing to
reflect upon us how I families divided
so there's a personal level in a
political level for both of that I think
my boob under some time if there might
be a slight group reaction against I'm
detour nastic families following the
Democrats experience with Al Gore in two
thousand and castling Kennedy Townsend
in 2002 I'm i think boop oop with gore
you had on someone who looked terrific
on paper who will poop us I mean every
room AC run it knowing every group race
he won he ran on either you know to fill
a safe that that had been held by his
father I'm where is Bill Clinton's from
proof writing made and it turned out
that when he had to tread himself under
extremely high pressure his two
campaigns for president people were not
run too terribly well and I had kind of
the same thing will poop with Kathleen
Kennedy towns and I mean I willful bunch
of tacoma kratz boom item to be
wondering if it's so good to take on
faith someone who know the family name
who hasn't really been tested by
themselves in a really tough race
someone else Oh Peter oh I was just
gonna make a comment on on you know the
issue does come up about you know skull
and bones and these issues and I think
it's very interesting when you look at
in the context of the Bush family I
think that demonstrates this sort of
social migration that I talked about
George Herbert Walker Bush the father is
a Yalie true and true I mean he goes to
the reunions he goes to Skull and Bones
unions when he was elected president
when the first things he did was have a
reunion of his class of skullenbones he
gives to the Russell Russell trust
association which is the scholarship
fund for skullenbones George W Bush
largely couldn't care less I mean he
turned his back on Yale and walked away
and largely turned his back on Skull and
Bones when when he was tapped to join
bones by his father by the way he was
supposed to come up with a name they all
have these sort of strange quirky names
well he didn't really think about it so
they gave him the name temporary that
it's that's been his name in skull and
bones for 30-something years because
it's not something that is really that
importance and he doesn't go to the
reunions he's not very active we
interviewed people from bones that are
three generations in the family and just
the level of commitment that George W
Bush has to those institutions Eastern
institutions of his father are just not
really that strong and I think that sort
of demonstrates the cultural migration
of the bushes have gone through over the
last half century it's a couple of
points 1 is the Yale and the other IVs
and other elite schools are now
struggling with this whole notion of
entitlement and obviously they're moving
away somewhat under pressure from legacy
admissions and they're talking very
openly Larry Summers the president of
Harvard
richard levin the president of Yale as
well about how their ideal in fact is to
open up these spring boards to a much
wider range of people because they
clearly are spring boards to something
something greater having said that if
you look at the Democratic nomination
process Howard Dean who also had this
kind of level of privilege obviously
emerged early it's very hard to make the
case that that's why he emerged early
and he didn't have that same kind of
network and while John Kerry won the
nomination against other contenders Dick
Gephardt uh John Edwards and wes clark
none of whom had those advantages all of
whom came from barely middle-class
families and succeeded on their own uh
the reason that Kerry emerged was not
because of skull and bones it was
because unlike many of his fellow Yale
ease and classmates he went to Vietnam
won a silver star a Bronze Star and uh
and for Democrats looking for somebody
who could match up on the broader
national security front that was what
gave Carrie the edge that allowed him to
win a nomination a couple of tweaks here
and there and it might very well have
been a John Edwards and we would have
had a slightly different story another
question or comment another question or
comment gentleman in the back there take
the microphone please sorry unless I
miss his opening remarks but i wonder if
Peter could compare his book to say the
Kevin Phillips book the other end
rubbish book which is yours is generally
and then the canned full of the
anti-bush books well that's a good
question I have a lot of respect for the
work that Kevin Phillips has done in the
back I have some serious concerns about
American dynasty and I've written about
that in National Review and I think what
happens is that because the bushes are
secretive because we are in a hotly
contested political campaign that
invites a lot of wild theories about why
things happen
and probably the biggest concern that I
have about the chem Phillips book and I
won't go on about it long because he's
not here to defend himself obviously is
that just some of the sourcing I mean
that he relies on things like the
Adamson report which is a report
published by a guy who runs a website
called CIA JFK who argues that the
bushes among other things were involved
the assassination of Princess Diana this
is some of the sourcing that is actually
used in the Kevin Phillips book I think
there's some historical information and
analysis it's very useful and helpful
but I think in the context of wanting to
sort of you know inject himself into the
hot political climate he's really
stepped over bounds I think with a lot
of the sourcing and the sort of material
that he would not have used I think a
couple years ago what we I think trying
to present as a human portrait of the
family warts and all certainly there
people think we are too pro-bush there
are certainly other people who think
that we raise matters that we shouldn't
but we try to paint a human portrait of
what is the dynamic between members of
the family how does the history the
family relate to the future of the
family and how is George W Bush the
person how was he formed and how what he
does now is that shaped by the family
and you know I think as norm mention at
the beginning you have this strand of
the family the bushes and the walkers
the walkers who are whiskey drinking a
loud and aggressive Catholics from st.
Louis and the bushes who are reserved
Victorians from Ohio you really do see
those two competing trends in in the
family and and you know i would say
George Walker Bush the current president
you know Walker in his in his name for a
reason and you really do see the lineage
their final question lady over here
America had a Japanese journalist you
mentioned about the sense of public
service in the Bush family and I
wondering what kind of sense of public
service you got from current president
because I don't really
you know I'm having hard time to sing
that from his you know policies and from
his background so if you can expand on
that well I think you know when the
bushes think of public service they
think about serving in government and
putting up with the press attention and
the scrutiny that legitimately comes
with that they also look at it in the
context of how it disrupts their lives
invades their privacy causes you know
additional attention to extended members
of the family so I think when they look
at public service running for governor
for example in Texas you know they view
that as something that's important for
them to do they've been given a lot in
life by their status and by their
position and they need to repay it back
and you know there's a high cost as
Naomi and everybody here is talking
about there's a high cost that comes
with public service so I think in the
case of george w bush you're talking
about running for governor the fact that
he was governor and you know it might
have been might it would have been
easier for him at a certain level to
simply just you know make the money off
his baseball team and enjoy life in
texas which I do think honestly he would
have been prepared to do i do think that
unlike his father who really felt like
he had to be sort of the top of the game
in public life george w bush simply does
not have that and you know the
interesting thing maybe for either
Norman a only to comment on you know
this whole issue of motivation because
you have with the Kennedys the
motivation coming from from parents sort
of driving you and you have george HW
bush I think self-motivated to say i
need to you know i want to be president
that was something he thought of in the
early 1960s with george w bush you don't
really quite have either one of those
for much of his life so it's really
quite interesting in that regard did you
think the jib I've been paid up his mind
he wanted to be president at an early
age Jeb Bush uh yeah my sense we
interviewed jab and it was really the
1980 presidential campaign when he
worked with his father that he got the
political bug and if you notice after
nineteen eighty that's when he got
involved in running
Republican Committee in Florida he also
actually considered running in 1986 for
Congress I talked to his father and his
father suggested that he not do it so
yes Jeb very much early on I did have
that motivation and what's interesting
is you have the pattern there again in
that if you look at Jeb and George W and
then you look at his father's generation
in both instances it's the second-born
son who is motivated not the firstborn
but the second-born son who is highly
motivated very early on to run for
president let me draw the panel to a
close with this question for our
panelists mindful of Sam Goldwyn famous
dictum never prophecy especially about
the future let me ask all of you if
you're willing to hazard a guess a
short-term and long-term prediction the
short-term one is obvious how you think
the election will go and that's really
less interesting i think the long-term
prediction which I guess I last this way
will we two generations from now see the
bushes on the scene in the same way the
Adams has went for three four
generations or what do you think you
know opinion on that Peter's start with
you well in terms of the future I mean
part of it you have to I think look at
you know the long-term sustainability of
the dynasty in the context of a birth
rate and what's interesting is is that
while previous generations the bush
dynasty would have four or five children
so you have a larger pool of people to
draw from you have in you know more
recent generations of the family fewer
and fewer children so I think just but
the law of averages of potential
recruits to go into politics is is lower
I think it's also going to be
interesting to see whether having been
in public life for more than half a
century whether some of the attraction
to it is lessened I think that politics
is much more intrusive now than it was
you know when prescott bush was in the
Senate the glare of public life was not
so intense so when Jeb and George W
would see him and spend time with him I
think they had a much more genteel view
of politics when they grew up then the
current generations of blisters are so I
think
certainly there's the potential with
some of the children like George P but I
think that you know remains to be seen
whether we'll still be talking about
them 40 or 50 years from now no mean am
I couldn't begin to predict anything you
know you know even to the election to
too many really unexpected things can
happen and they unexpected things happen
every day so actually we could probably
add to the dictum never make predictions
especially about the future and now it's
make the most outlandish predictions and
you'll get your own cable talk show uh
but not on c-span uh having said that
two points the first is uh in this
election the most curious element and
it's actually something that's worth
exploring and I would urge you to do so
in the in the future Peter George W Bush
ran as a uniter not a divider and he's
proven to be an extraordinarily divisive
president he has more support among
Republicans than Ronald Reagan had he
has less support among Democrats than
Richard Nixon had accepted the absolute
depths of the impeachment process and
that's made it extremely close it's a
very different governing style than he
employed as a governor of Texas it's a
radically different governing style than
his father employed and he's done it
partly in reaction to his father's
governance and loss in much the same way
I think we could look at the foreign
policy issues so that makes it difficult
to predict looking ahead we have
obviously two outcomes in 2004 if George
Bush loses it's hard to imagine that Jeb
Bush or any other Bush can stand up and
say oh boy now it's my turn if George
Bush wins frankly of John Kerry wins
governing in America in two thousand and
five and six and seven is going to be
nasty and brutish the party that loses
this election is going to feel bitter
and vindictive and will be in no mood to
govern in a bipartisan way and frankly
given the style that Bush has
consciously chosen to make a u-turn in
2005 and say let us now reason together
will be very very difficult to do under
those circumstances given that nastiness
I think another Bush stepping forward
for 2008 may not look
as attractive to people either so poor
Jeb may be screwed coming and going as
what you might say here and looking to
future generations of course it's
impossible to predict there is an
advantage but it's hard to see right now
very many people in this